Couchsurfing can bring an element of safety to traveling...
...which some people may not think of immediately.
Your host knows your environment so well in that local area.
They can show you around.
They know where the hospitals are.
Make you aware of which street is safe to go.
You can see things and be exposed to things that are off the beaten trail.
You are surfing to have a different experience.
I've couchsurfed single.
I met my husband through couchsurfing.
I've couchsurfed pregnant and I'm couchsurfing with our toddler now.
I think sometimes we forget how great people are.
We have all the horror stories in the media and you get a little bit protective...
...and worried about the outside world.
But couchsurfing reminds you how great the outside world can be.